well that weekend storm brought some
major damage to several areas across the
valley those strong wind gusts really
the main factor
sally jeremiah is live over the west
wind drive-in theater as you look over
sally's right shoulder you can see the
mess that is still
there left behind sally
brian a very scary situation on saturday
strong wind gusts up to 72 miles per
hour
caused damages like this it also
uprooted and split trees
we've had that before in las vegas but
not as
micro as this one misha on of vegas best
tree service
can't believe the damage the storm
caused it was like a magic
saturday 2 p.m uh the clear sky
as it is today uh blue sky and then all
of a sudden in half an hour the big
dark cloud comes in uh when increased
where you have to hold the wheel when
you're driving with two hands
so that the car doesn't get blown after
the storm passed
his phone was ringing non-stop about
30 calls per hour and
from there we mobilized those the crews
put everybody on
overtime uh night work anything that we
could do to help people drive
non-stop from the time we got the first
call up until it was really dark
uh we was actually doing estimates with
a flashlight
sharon macmillan was caught in the storm
it's been a long time since she's seen
that kind of wind
when we got home we noticed that one of
our trees was tilting towards the
neighbors cars and house while some
trees in your yard are vulnerable
to high winds anab recommends year-round
maintenance
i recommend to do pruning trimming of
the trees so that wind can go
through the trees without pushing onto
the academy and putting it into your
neighbor's house
as for this drive-in movie theater they
will start the clean up process
tomorrow morning and they do want to
remind everyone that their location
is still open reporting live sally
caramillo 8 news now